RELATIONSHIP WITH THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, 2024 RACE, THE IMPACT
OF THE JANUARY 6th HEARINGS.
>> WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO HAVE?
>> I THINK I'M GOING TO GET
DUMPLINGS.
>> I'M SORRY I'M LATE.
HOT AND SOUR SOUP.
THAT'S WHAT I WAS GOING HAVE.
>> OKAY.
>> NICE BOWL OF SOUP ON A COLD
DAY.
>> YOU ACTUALLY FIRST MET AT A
MEAL LIKE THIS IN 1987.
>> LIKE JANUARY.
AND GEORGE MILLER, WHO WAS MY
ROOMMATE, MY LANDLORD, HE SAID
THERE IS A NEW PERSON JOINING
OUR GROUP.
HER NAME IS NANCY PELOSI.
SHE IS THE NEW CONGRESS MEMBER
FROM SAN FRANCISCO, AND SHE --
BEFORE I MET HER, SHE WILL
BECOME THE FIRST WOMAN SPEAKER.
THAT'S WHAT HE SAID.
GOD'S TRUTH.
>> HE WAS RIGHT.
>> WHAT WAS INTERESTING ABOUT
IT --
>> YOU REALLY KNEW THE FIRST
TIME?
>> I KNEW SHE WOULD REALLY BE A
FORCE.
>> WHATEVER THAT MIGHT BE.
>> WOULD YOU LIKE FOR SOME
APPETIZERS?
>> SO I'LL HAVE AN ORDER OF
SHRIMP DUMPLINGS.
>> OKAY.
>> AND THEN I'LL HAVE SOME
STRING BEANS.
>> TALK TO ME ABOUT YOUR
RELATIONSHIP.
THE TWO OF YOU FINISH EACH
OTHER'S SENTENCES.
YOU'RE ON THE PHONE CONSTANTLY,
FOUR --
>> 455-730 -- AND I'M NOT GOING
TO SAY THE LAST.
>> OH, PLEASE.
YOU KNOW EVERYBODY'S PHONE
NUMBER.
>> I PROBABLY DIAL HERS JUST
ABOUT MORE THAN ANYONE OTHER
THAN PEOPLE IN MY FAMILY.
>> HERE IS THE THING.
I SAY THIS ALL THE TIME.
HE HAS -- WHAT DO YOU CALL THAT
PHONE?
>> A FLIP PHONE.
IF HE HAD A REGULAR SMARTPHONE,
WE COULD REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
CONVERSATIONS, BECAUSE I COULD
JUST TEXT HIM.
>> HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE YOUR
RELATIONSHIP, YOUR CALL?
THE POWER COUPLE, YOU'RE CALLED
AN ODD COUPLE.
>> WE'RE CLOSE FRIENDS.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE BROTHER AND
SISTER.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> WHEN YOU DISAGREE, WHO WINS?
>> USUALLY HER.
>> NO, NO.
WHEN WE DISAGREE, THEN WE END
THE CONVERSATION, AND WE KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO COME BACK.
>> A TOUGH ONE A WEEK AGO,
RIGHT?
WHAT WAS IT?
>> WHAT WAS IT ABOUT?
>> I DON'T REMEMBER WHAT IT WAS.
BUT IT WAS SHALL WE SAY CANDID.
>> I WANT TO TALK ABOUT HOW THE
TWO OF YOU NAVIGATED WORKING
WITH FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP,
BECAUSE OF --
>> WE HAD A GOOD TIME.
>> HE FAMOUSLY NICKNAMED THE TWO
OF YOU CHUCK AND NANCY, RIGHT?
IT WAS ALWAYS CHUCK AND NANCY.
I THINK YOU BOTH NEW THAT
SPEAKER PELOSI GOT UNDER HIS
SKIN, RIGHT?
>> YES.
>> WAS THERE A STRATEGY WHEN YOU
WENT IN TO A MEETING?
WAS THERE A GOOD COP/BAD COP?
>> HE'S JUST INAUGURATED.
THIS IS AN HISTORIC MOMENT.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
SO I'M THINKING HOW IS HE GOING
TO BEGIN?
IS HE GOING QUOTE THE
CONSTITUTION, AMERICAN HISTORY,
POET, THE BIBLE?
"YOU KNOW I WON THE POPULAR
VOTE."
>> THAT'S HOW HE STARTED.
>> AND I SAID, "MR. PRESIDENT,
THAT'S JUST NOT TRUE."
>> WE SORT OF SET HIM UP
INSTINCTIVELY.
WE DIDN'T PLAN THIS.
EVERYONE THOUGHT WE PLANNED THIS
OUT.
IT WAS ABOUT THE GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN THE FIRST TIME.
AND NANCY SAID SOMETHING TO HIM
ABOUT HE DIDN'T -- ABOUT WOMEN.
>> CHUCK WAS MASTERFUL.
HE WAS MASTERFUL.
>> SHE SET HIM UP SO I COULD GO
IN FOR THE KILL.
>> HE WAS MASTERFUL.
HE IS TALKING TO HIM ABOUT THE
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN AND ABOUT
IMMIGRANTS AND THE REST.
AND HE SAYS "I TAKE OWNERSHIP".
>> "MR. PRESIDENT, WILL YOU OWN
THE SHUTDOWN"?
"YES, I WILL."
>> THERE ARE A SERIES OF MOMENTS
THAT YOU SAW FIRSTHAND.
THERE IS THE CLAP.
THERE IS TEARING UP THE SPEECH,
AND THEN THERE IS THE FAMOUS
PICTURE.
IT'S THE MEETING IN THE CABINET
ROOM WHERE YOU STOOD UP AND
CONFRONTED.
LOOKING BACK AT THOSE MOMENTS,
WHAT WAS GOING THROUGH YOUR
MIND?
>> I SAID HE DOESN'T STAND A
CHANCE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
HE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT HE IS UP
AGAINST.
I TELL PEOPLE NANCY
INSTINCTIVELY KNEW HOW TO HANDLE
TRUMP, BECAUSE FOR HER FIRST,
YOU KNOW, 35, 40 YEARS OF LIFE,
SHE RAISED FIVE CHILDREN, AND
SHE KNEW HOW TO DEAL WITH
CHILDREN.
AND THAT'S WHAT HELP HERD DEAL
WITH TRUMP, BECAUSE HE
ULTIMATELY WAS A CHILD.
>> WE HAD A DIFFERENT APPROACH.
CHUCK IS A NEW YORKER.
>> BROOKLYN.
SO THEY SPOKE THEIR OWN KIND
OF -- THEY UNDERSTOOD EACH
OTHER.
>> JANUARY 6th, THERE IS
EXTRAORDINARY FOOTAGE OF THE TWO
OF YOU BEING EVACUATED WHAT WAS
IT LIKE THAT DAY?
>> IT WAS HORRIBLE.
I MEAN, IT WAS A HORRIBLE TIME.
>> IT WAS FRIGHTENING.
PEOPLE ARE INVADING THE CAPITOL.
WE WERE BOTH WORRIED ABOUT OUR
OWN MEMBERS, PEOPLE IN ANY
SENATE, PEOPLE IN THE HOUSE,
WHAT WAS HAPPENING TO THEM
BECAUSE THEY WHISKED US OFF TO
THIS OTHER PLACE.
FOR A WHILE, CELL PHONE SERVICE
DIDN'T HAPPEN.
AND IT WAS JUST FRIGHTENING.
>> DID YOU TRY TO REACH OUT TO
THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF?
>> YES.
THEY WASN'T PUT HIM ON.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, I THINK IT
WAS ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL, HE
WOULDN'T PUT HIM ON.
>> HE WOULDN'T TAKE YOUR CALLS?
>> THE PRESIDENT WOULDN'T,
THAT'S RIGHT.
>> I THINK YOU SEE IN SOME OF
THE FILM HOW FIRM CHUCK WAS WHEN
WE WERE CALLING THE GOVERNORS,
THE MAYORS, THE SECRETARY.
AND WE WERE TELLING THE
SECRETARY OF THE ARMY, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THE SECRETARY OF THE ARMY WAS
SUPPOSED -- IT'S REALLY A
TRAGEDY THAT THEY DID NOT SEND
THE NATIONAL GUARD EARLIER.
>> THEY WERE SORT OF AFRAID TO
ACT.
TRUMP HAD SO INTIMIDATED
EVERYBODY, YOU COULD NEVER TELL
HIM THE TRUTH.
YOU COULD NEVER CONTRADICT HIM.
HAVE SOME PEKING DUCK.
IT'S GOOD.
I'M EATING SO MUCH.
>> THERE IS A CNN POLL THAT JUST
CAME OUT THAT SHOWS THERE IS
STILL APPETITE ON BOTH SIDES FOR
A BIDEN-TRUMP REMATCH IN 2024.
YOU'RE STEPPING ASIDE.
DO YOU THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN
SHOULD STEP ASIDE FOR A YOUNGER
GENERATION?
>> I THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
DONE AN EXCELLENT JOB AS
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
I HOPE THAT HE DOES SEEK
REELECTION.
HE'S BEEN A GREAT PRESIDENT.
>> LOOK AT WHAT HE HAS
ACCOMPLISHED.
>> HE SHOULD RUN AGAIN.
>> HE HAS DONE AN EXCELLENT,
EXCELLENT JOB.
AND HE RUNS, I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT HIM ALL THE WAY.
>> RIGHT NOW, DONALD TRUMP IS
THE ONLY REPUBLICAN WHO IS
ANNOUNCED.
HE COULD BE THE NOMINEE.
HE COULD BE PRESIDENT AGAIN.
YOU'VE BEEN THROUGH THE FIRST
PRESIDENCY.
YOU'VE BEEN THROUGH JANUARY 6th.
WHAT WOULD IT MEAN IF DONALD
TRUMP WAS RE-ELECTED PRESIDENT?
>> I DON'T THINK IT WILL HAPPEN.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE GOTTEN
WISE TO HIM.
IT TOOK A LITTLE WHILE, BUT THEY
DID.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT WE SHOULD
TALK ABOUT HIM WHILE WE'RE
EATING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> SEE?
>> REALLY, ANOTHER TRUMP
PRESIDENCY?
>> YOU CALLED DONALD TRUMP,
QUOTE, INSANE.
>> I THINK THERE